another vaccine that has not yet been
approved in the united states
is running into trouble in other
countries charlie dagetta is in london
with that story
charlie good morning good morning well
it's the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
which has been suspended
across much of europe over concerns
about blood clots a decision
experts here are calling a disaster
more than a dozen countries have halted
the use of the vaccine including
germany france and italy as a
precautionary measure
but regulators here insist there is no
link between the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine and a higher incidence of blood
clots
astrazeneca says a review of 17 million
people here in the uk and in europe
who've received the vaccine found less
than 40 developed blood clots in their
words
even lower than you'd expect to find in
the general population
and we have found similar numbers across
all vaccines including moderna and
pfizer
currently in use in the u.s now the
decision to spend the oxford vaccine now
comes as coveted cases are spreading
exponentially in parts of europe causing
further lockdowns
as for the u.s there are 300 million
doses of this oxford vaccine waiting for
fda approval astrazeneca says
they're hoping to submit the vaccine for
approval in april
gail all right thank you very much
charlie dagetta reporting from london